[Música]
a veces me pregunto
si de verdad se acabó el amor
veo y escucho por todos lados que las
relaciones entre los géneros se están
cambiando
y en los últimos tiempos rapidísimo
se escucha una consigna que dice se va a
caer se va a caer
se caerá el patriarcado y se llevará
consigo el amor
y entender que está vivo y causando mil
y una enredos en las relaciones
afectivas y entonces me pregunto hay
posibilidad de reconstruir algo o el
futuro amoroso será inevitablemente un
páramo de soledad y crueldad
un pibe me consultó hace poco y me dijo
me mande un moco con mi ex novia hace un
tiempo y ella me acaba de escrachar
no me dijo a qué se refería con esto de
mandarse un moco me lo tuve que imaginar
y entonces empecé a pensar empecé a
repasar mentalmente
la habrá forzado a tener relaciones
sexuales que ella no quería
habrá aprovechado en alguna fiesta que
ya estaba fumada o tomada y la habrá
forzado a tener sexo con otros pibes
habrá sido violento con ella para
resolver algún conflicto o simplemente
la habrá dejado plantada sin aviso
solo me dice que sabe que lo que hizo no
está bien
pero también me dice que lo sabe ahora
no lo sabía entonces
me cuenta que una vez la vio mal y le
preguntó qué le pasaba
y ella le explico
y a él le pareció que ya era un poquito
exagerada
que no entendía que los hombres somos
así
que tendría que ser un poquito más piola
y abierta
pero eso lo sabe ahora no lo sabía
entonces
sabes lo que me pasaba
yo no pensaba en lo que mis conductas
podían causar en las demás personas y
mucho menos en las mujeres hacía lo que
me pintaba lo que me parecía
y ahora que sé quiero saber hay algo que
yo pueda hacer para mejorar
o mi pasado me condena
a mí no me deja de sorprender que por
fin hayamos llegado a un momento
histórico en el cual los varones se
empiezan a cuestionar sus privilegios y
el dolor que los mismos pueden causar en
los demás
y hay mucho que se puede hacer con esto
el este pibe hay mucho que puede hacer
para mejorar la situación
te sugiero que le pidas perdón' que
escribas y le digas que bojan o social
que eras que cambiaste y hoy sos a
alguien que le importa el dolor que
causan la otra persona y trata de
evitarlo en lo que puede
qué pasa si ella no me contesta o no le
interesa estar en contacto conmigo
no insistas aceptas uno
de esa manera se va a dar cuenta que sos
sincero
y algo va a cambiar en ella y en voz
hay algo sanador en encontrarse con
alguien que puede revisarse a sí mismo
y perdonar no implica recomponer el
vínculo
sólo implica sacarse de adentro el dolor
que implica sostener un rencor
por mi trabajo he hablado con muchísimas
mujeres sobre estos temas y ellas me
enseñaron que están esperando que los
varones pidan perdón por las cosas que
les hicieron que se hagan cargo de sus
acciones pero fundamentalmente que no
las hagan más
y esto pasa mucho pero que pase mucho no
es que esté bien y los varones no lo
hacen porque sean ni enfermos ni malos
sino que lo hacen porque son hijos sanos
del patriarcado
y eso tiene remedio
es la famosa deconstrucción de la
masculinidad hegemónica
así como ningún pibe nace chorro ningún
pibe nace macho
[Aplausos]
eso se aprende y si se aprende se puede
desaprender
podemos enseñar a los pibes desde
chiquitos desde el jardín hacer
diferentes
que ser varón no sea nunca más poner en
riesgo a alguien
las mujeres nos hemos ganado y ahí lo
digo en primera persona a ser sujetas en
paridad también en el sexo y el amor
eso es algo que mi generación de mujeres
deseaba pero no creíamos que íbamos a
alcanzar a ver
todo esto me dejó pensando sobre las
relaciones entre los sujetos y el poder
qué hacemos cuando tenemos más poder que
la otra persona por ejemplo los padres
con los hijos los varones con las
mujeres los hijos adultos con los padres
viejos
nos controlamos en nuestra propia
agresividad o hacemos lo que queremos
porque podemos
y qué pasa cuando se da vuelta a la
tortilla cuando por ejemplo yo he sido
una mujer víctima
y ya tengo más poder o cuando por
ejemplo crecí y ya no soy más ni una
niña ni un niño y un niño
ni una línea
me como el caníbal y me transformó en
caníbal
o tengo otra salida
yo creo que hablar de todos estos temas
nos puede ayudar a callar nuevo diálogo
y ojalá un nuevo guión amoroso entre los
géneros
la pregunta del millón hoy es cómo poder
recomponer de manera no autoritaria y
sin nostalgia por el pasado las
relaciones entre los géneros puede
construir un modo de amorosidad que esté
muy lejos de la bella y la bestia' y
mucho más cerca de las mujeres y los
varones actuales
y esto que les cuento también pasa en
las adolescencias en los colegios
en los últimos tiempos ha habido muchas
situaciones de abuso muchas denuncias de
abuso y también acciones autogestivas de
defensa que se llaman escraches todo el
año pasado estuve trabajando en un
colegio secundario porque había muchos
problemas
las autoridades nos llamaron porque el
clima de hostilidades
era altísimo esa escuela se había
convertido en un lugar muy feo para
estar para todo el mundo
y nos pidieron que trabajemos con los
grupos problemáticos
pero no hicimos eso ofrecimos trabajar
con todo el mundo porque porque los
grupos problemáticos
son sólo la punta del iceberg de un
fenómeno muchísimo más extenso que es el
malestar actual de las relaciones entre
los géneros
y esto es porque estalló el orden sexual
de la modernidad
entonces trabajamos con todo el mundo
trabajamos con el alumnado trabajamos
con familias
trabajamos con docentes trabajamos con
autoridades
transmitimos nuestra visión del tema
pero también escuchamos lo que tenían
para decirnos y así en el diálogo
escuchando nos apareció la idea de que
había una salida
y una idea también muy poderosa que
escuchándonos todos juntos en diferencia
había una esperanza y en ese ida y
vuelta apareció la creatividad del ex
pibes
ya no eran solo varaderos que había que
controlar o vigilar
parte de su creatividad es el
consentimiento
esto es preguntar si la otra persona
quiere lo mismo que yo y aceptar su
respuesta
hay un mito por ahí que dice que te la
baja que te quita pero eso no es verdad
es un muy buen invento autogestivo
y no los sacaron de la nada los sacaron
por ejemplo de los protocolos médicos de
ello que cuando nos hacemos un estudio
firmamos o de lo que hacemos quienes
investigamos con personas que les
contamos lo que vamos a hacer con ellas
y les pedimos que nos firmen que están
de acuerdo
los sacaron de esos lugares y lo
pusieron a disposición de las nuevas
formas de amar y de desear y de tener
sexo pero sin lastimar y sin abusar
y les preguntan personalmente por
whatsapp o por cualquier tipo de
aplicación da para darse
el consentimiento de hoy es como el
preservativo en los años 90 cuando fue
la epidemia de la hb
entonces también decían que te la bajaba
pero no fue así
se inventaron 1000 tipos de
preservativos de todos los colores
sabores y texturas
sólo guns cómo póntelo pónselo úsalo no
sea y mil maneras diferentes de
seguir amando deseando y teniendo sexo
entonces con un nuevo amigo el
el nuevo amigo hoy es el consentimiento
[Aplausos]
no tiene que ser por formulario triple
puede ser juguetón a la manera de cada
quien pero de cualquier modo que sea que
permita que ambos seamos sujetos que
podamos decir no y que podamos decir sí
y muestra que donde algunos ven el fin
del amor otros inventan maneras de
seguir amando deseando y teniendo sexo
pero incorporando lo nuevo
que no es otra cosa que algo muy antiguo
que necesita reformularse no le hagas al
otro lo que no quieras que te hagan a
vos
[Aplausos]
cómo transformar la crueldad en ternura
en las relaciones entre los géneros si
encontramos la respuesta esa herramienta
la podemos utilizar para otro tipo de
relaciones donde haya diferencias de
poder
y si resulta que no se acabó el amor y
lo que se acabó es un tipo de amor y una
forma de relacionarse entre los géneros
donde no hay amor hay crueldad
bienvenidos entonces las nuevas formas
de amar y de desear para que la igualdad
y la autonomía no tengan como contracara
la soledad y la tristeza
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]